[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment mon métier d'animateur me
pousse à vous demander avez vous déjà
oui dans un jacuzzi
c'est là où on voit qu'elle sait
vraiment intégré c'est qu'on n'a même
plus besoin de moi alors je racontais
bas j'étais un peu malade et je vous dit
j'ai voulu traiter
est ce que est ce que vous restez bien
qu'à un moment donné où vous prenez
entre le moment où l'idée géniale
symbole arrivée la bouche ou petit fils
sans de se dire tiens ce que je dis est
ce que je le dis pour l'été avec ton mec
l'intel labs enjeu est donc alors qu'est
ce que vous avez fait venir parce que
c'est ce qui est intéressant
j'ai pleuré à chaque fois vous pétez non
mais là c'est un peu dégueulasse et je
me suis dit mon père et va manquer ces
deux rendez vous et de votre père voilà
alors commence à sévir
en fait je regrette c'est un peu ce nom
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il suffisait d'appuyer sur la touche
filtre elle commence à comprendre que
maintenant il va falloir réfléchir un
petit peu mais c'est ce qui fait votre
salon cap nous racontiez pas ça
évidemment ça serait moins drôle